[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to your first unboxing of the
brand new iphone 10s and 10s max video
one of two for the day again so yes
these are the newest phones they're both
the gold color and they're both also the
512 gig which means these are some
pretty expensive phones but this is just
your look at the unboxing experience and
you'll notice uh the clever wallpaper to
hide the notch
you know as much as they want us to
embrace that notch that is a lot of work
to cleverly hide at apple icu also fun
fact there is a slightly different
planet on each box they're not identical
anyway let's not waste our time let's
get right into the box because it's
actually not the same as iphone
unboxings from years in the past you'll
see that in a second so at the top you
get in there and it's the paperwork
again designed by apple in california i
sure hope so and in the sleeve you get
your apple stickers you get your sim
card ejector tool
and the quick start guide this stuff is
actually the same so no need to pay any
special attention to it you can toss
that to the side and next up is of
course the iphone itself and all its
glass stainless steel and gold glory
it's looking pretty clean but we'll get
to that in a second too
underneath the iphone is the charging
brick and under here too is the
lightning cable it comes with i was kind
of hoping by 2018 we could get either a
fast charger in the box or a usbc to
lightning charger or or both uh but we
get neither of those things i personally
think it's getting kind of lame and kind
of outdated that apple of all companies
doesn't ship a fast charger in the box
of such an expensive premium phone just
saying anyway you put that to the side
and you have your headphones here which
look the way they normally do but when
you turn it around this time
they're missing one thing
so yeah that's right confirmed no
headphone jack dongle in the box of the
iphone 10s so all these previous iphones
with no headphone jacks have always come
with a little lightning to headphone
jack dongle in the box very considerate
this year it's gone now you know if
you're buying a thousand dollar phone or
even a
fifty 1450 phone like we have here you
probably wouldn't blink twice at buying
a little eight dollar adapter
but it's clearly done on purpose apple
can afford to put the dongle in there
but they chose not to this time trying
to nudge people again towards wireless
or lightning headphones also fun fact in
case you didn't know the best-selling
product in apple stores and in retail
stores i guess by volume for the last
two years has been dongles
this will not change that anyway here's
the phone and we can take a second to
admire it as clean and scratch free as
it'll probably ever be in its life
and that completes your unboxing
experience for the record it is exactly
the same on the smaller 10s but we'll go
through that anyway now by the time you
see this i will have actually been using
the iphones for a couple days since the
launch event so this was recorded a
couple days ago so lucky for you the
full review which has been in the works
is also launching today as well dropping
exactly 12 hours so 12 hours from the
launch of this video check back to your
sub boxes 6 pm eastern for the full
iphone 10s and 10s plus
review so that should be fun also after
setting up the iphones real quick i want
to share with you the new wallpapers for
these new phones there's always new
wallpapers with new iphones i'll try to
get them on twitter if i can but check
out these three new live ones if you
haven't seen them yet
they are super cool and they look
incredible on this inky oled display the
super high resolution with the deep
blacks but of course don't let that
distract you from the fact that they're
still hiding the notch perfectly um but
this this might be the best use of 3d
touch at the moment honestly
anyway that's your unboxings thanks for
watching it's a quick video but stay
tuned shortly for the full review i'll
see you guys over there
thanks for watching
peace
you